huge congratulations on this movie thank
you so much happy to speak with you i've
seen it twice now and i expected it to
be a lot of fun but i'm like still blown
away by how incredibly smart that script
is
did you see it in the theater in the
cinema with other folks i did i did the
first time i i was not with a lot of
people and then the second time i was
with a packed house and like it plays
well in both scenarios but man with a
crowd is it powerful
i'm glad you said so i had the same
experience in texas and i was so happy
it felt like a return to what i call the
church of the cinema where everybody in
the room was like a family member of
sorts we were all laughing together
there was an electricity in the room and
i i i it made me very really warm my
heart and i do recommend seeing this
movie in the theater okay so that leads
into my first question here because back
in the fall you told one of my
colleagues that you would never watch
the unbearable weight of massive talent
so now that you've seen it are you glad
you watched it and is there anything you
took from it that surprised you
well i had to watch it because my other
hat on this movie was producer and as a
producer it got to a point where
you know the studio had an opinion and
the director had an opinion and it was
time for fresh eyes and i had to you
know shut off half my
mind and half my heart and look at it
the movie from a place of neutral and as
a producer i was able to say
you know to the studio i think you got
to put some of tom's flavor back in the
movie you're losing a lot of the flavor
of the comedy
and to tom i had to say i think these
two scenes aren't landing and i'm glad i
did it because i think we finally got to
a place where the movie works as a whole
in the best possible way the best of
both worlds um
you know
but seeing it in the theater just as an
audience member that was fun that was
really great just because i'm curious
now what specifically is that tom flavor
that you think the movie needed more of
well you know
not worrying so much about checking all
the boxes
you know with a uh
mike what do they call that those groups
yeah thank you focus groups you know
like well we got to make the character
more likeable more likeable and then
they lose some of the
you know self-deprecating humor or the
or the the irreverent humor that tom had
like okay the piano scene where i'm the
character is drunk and he's playing
piano he's making a mess at the birthday
party they they homogenized it so much
that the the nick cage character wasn't
doing anything wrong and everybody was
rolling their eyes like well he's just
singing a sweet song to his daughter you
got to make it more of a train wreck at
the risk of him being less likable
because the character has to grow he has
to evolve into a sensitive family man
in my own life nicholas cage
begins as family first i'm not someone
who's a career-minded person that at the
at the sacrifice of his family but that
was
not the story tom gorman was trying to
tell all right big broad question before
they kicked me out of here so obviously
your filmography is incredible it's just
packed with very different bold roles
and you know it's always made me wonder
does anything scare you have you ever
been offered a part and said to yourself
like i i don't know if i could do that
yeah this one this was the most
terrifying thing i've ever done in my
entire body of work i mean i think i've
done some of the best work in the last
10 years of my entire life and i put
massive talent in that period
which has been in some ways marginalized
by certain folks in the media but i
think i'll put pig and massive talent
and mandy and color out of space and bad
lieutenant and joe and the trust and the
what the the runner up against anything
i did in the first 30 years but in all
that time in the 43 years i've been
doing it massive talent is hands down
the scariest thing i've ever done
paid off to jump feet first into that
then so huge congratulations to you and
i cannot wait to watch this over and
over
you